small cute and agile those are the
attributes that helped the autobianchi
a112 lay the groundwork for a new model
segment when the a112 was introduced in
the fall of 1969 car lovers got more
than just an Italian version of
Britain's mini our test driver says it's
fun driving through the mountains of
South Tirol at an autobianchi a112 what
could be better
you could zip along all the way to
Remini and treat yourself to a gelato
but you must really put the pedal to the
metal to reveal the cars Italian
temperament the medicine eater uses
temperament invited
the a112 was the first truly drivable
supermini it was produced by Fiat
subsidiary auto Bianchi which functioned
as a test lab for new car concepts in
the 1960s Fiats first front-wheel drive
vehicle the Primula was also created by
Otto Bianchi in 1964 this a 112 is a 44
horsepower transversely mounted
four-cylinder engine with a capacity of
903 cubic centimeters our driver says
the car's biggest weakness is the
transmission many people say it's a bit
clunky but our tester doesn't notice
that he says the ride is comfortable and
the car takes curves well to him the
suspensions not as stiff as the Mini
Coopers or other cars of its kind but
then the mini was a real race car in the
1960s the little British pocket rocket
won the Monte Carlo Rally three times in
a row still the first minis to roll off
the production lines in 1959 were
designed to be practical everyday
vehicles the cars designers Sir Alec
Issigonis wanted to pack for people and
their belongings into a car just three
metres long in 1969 a decade after the
mini the auto Bianchi began taking part
in rallies in the 1980s the company
started to market the a112 as a Lancia
Christophe says people who can build a
city like this must also be able to
build good cars the auto Bianchi is at
home and little Italian alleyways like
this Italy has a long tradition of
producing small cars
the Fiat Nova cinquecento brought
mobility to an entire nation and reduced
car driving to it's very essentials the
little car rolled off the assembly lines
for almost two decades from 1957 to 1976
the a112 like the Fiat 500 was the baby
of designer Dante chakuza
Christophe says if anyone can build
small cars
it's the Italians the English have their
mini but everything that annoys him
about the mini behave 1:12 does better
it's bigger 13-inch tires make the ride
more comfortable and he says it has a
real hatchback and that handyman types
will love the fold down rear seats he
says it's almost the size of a truck
back here and the gas tanks found in
front of the rear axle the car offers a
lot of space and great views it's super
he says
a little engine has little trouble
propelling the 685 kilo lightweight
around car originally sold for around
2500 euros the only extra was the
tachometer when the a112 came onto the
market in 1969 christophe says it was
the only serious supermini
it's a real car that drives well even
today it's great fun to drive he adds
the a 112 maybe an automotive milestone
but it isn't showing its age this once
trend-setting italian super mini turns
45 this year
you